dormir sur le ventre au niveau des
postures ça respecte pas du tout les
courbures du dos c'est différent selon
qu'on est du ventre et de la poitrine ou
pas du tout selon que notre matelas soit
mou ou pas du tout mais globalement pour
la colonne vertébrale c'est pas génial
avec une petite mention spéciale pour
les cervicales qui sont vraiment
complètement tordus parce que on a la
tête complètement sur le côté à moins
d'avoir la tête complètement dans
laurier mais là on meurt ce n'est pas
très bon pour la santé enfin plus
sérieusement quand on est sur le ventre
la cage thoracique se développe pas tout
à fait correctement donc en plus on
respire moins bien comme notre poids
repose sur notre ventre donc sur notre
estomac pour les histoires de digestion
et pour les problèmes de remontée acide
c'est pas génial non en plus on dort la
bouche ouverte là on bave sur l'oreiller
c'est dégueulasse ça pue donc